[Music]
we must insist that the Border be the
top priority I I think we have some
consensus around that table everyone
understands the urgency of that and
we're going to continue to press for it
well that's what uh speaker Mike Johnson
took away from his meeting with Joe
Biden and other top Congressional
leaders about the so-called border
negotiations and the Ukraine Aid deal
now many congressional Republicans have
been trying to tie money for Ukraine for
some faux border deal which would be of
course a political win for the Democrats
but I think Senate Democrats look they
have a different idea there's a large
amount of agreement around the table
that we must do Ukraine and we must do
border there was tremendous focus on
Ukraine and in understanding that if we
don't come to Ukraine's Aid that the
consequences for America around the
globe would be nothing short of
devastating joining me now for his first
interview on the angle since becom
speaker and since coming out of that
meeting is Speaker of the House Mike
Johnson Mr speaker thank you so much for
joining us um the the president actually
uh just got off the phone with me right
before the show and he said he has
spoken to you about this deal and that
he is against it and he urged you to be
against this deal he was extremely
president Trump was extremely adamant
about that um your reaction to that
given the fact that look he already he
knows how to do this enforcement and
stuff you don't need some new bill
coming out of the uh the Senate to get
the Border
enforced yeah president Trump is not
wrong he and I've been talking about
this um uh pretty frequently I talked to
him night before last about the same
subject we don't have the text of
whatever the Senate has cooked up yet
and and so we have to reserve judgment I
think to see what comes out of it it
doesn't sound good uh at the outset but
what I told the the President Biden at
the White House today is the same thing
that I've been saying to him since I was
handed the gavl to become speaker and
that is our border our national border
is National Security and we have to talk
about the safety and the the the
security and the sovereignty of America
before we talk about anything else that
has to be top of mind that's what the
American people demand that's what they
deserve and that's what the house of
Republicans are united around so that is
the battle and we got to get it done the
the Republican Grassroots I think by the
reaction on social media were really
encouraged by your tweets that the
Langford bill is a no-o and and the text
of that bill I think is already written
it has been written for some time and it
included 5,000 minimum uh migrants to be
waved into the country um every day
which is 1.82 five million a year and
now um You said it's not the time for
comprehensive immigration reform which
is really amnesty so that was really
encouraging but then at 6:03 p.m.
eastern time today Mr Speaker the hill
posted a story with this title Johnson
gets squeezed by Biden's Senate GOP on
Ukraine and the Border your reaction to
that yeah I I don't know what what
they're talking about Laura we haven't
seen that text yet this Senators the
Republicans who are engaged in the
negotiation on the other side say that
some of those claims aren't true we
again we have to Reser Reserve judgment
because that text has not been posted
yet and we've not seen it I mean I'm
hopeful that they'll come up with
something meaningful but what I have
said from the very beginning is that we
have to have hr2 or the functional
equivalent thereof why because it has
very important Provisions we reform
Asylum and the broken parole process we
restore the Trump error remain in Mexico
policy which is essential and you end
Catch and Release we need to rebuild the
wall there are other elements as well
but some of those are essential to stop
the flow but Mr Speaker yeah Mr Speaker
I'm sorry to interrupt but I I I've I've
been doing this immigration thing for
like 30 years here long before you came
here but they could do that tonight ex
they don't need the lenford bill to do
remain in Mexico or to enforce our
border they do not have good faith on
this issue they do not want the border
to be secure because if they did they
would have secured it over the last 3
years so then you show up at the White
House and like trying to Strongarm you
to agree to something that has been
written by Schumer staff for months yeah
Laura no one is strong arming me I told
the president I looked right across the
table from him in the cabinet uh
officials room and I said Mr President
you have the authority right now in this
catastrophe it's your actions that
created it in fact Mr President I told
him in the meeting today we've
documented 6 four instances of you
taking executive actions in your
agencies that created this catastrophe
Mr President it's on you to unwind it we
don't need new laws you could do it
right now I've cited to him read him the
legal Authority on the phone on Thursday
of last week that he could take and you
know what he said in the meeting Lauren
he said we're ready to do big things on
the border well Hallelujah Mr president
President Biden do your job fix the
catastrophe that you've created it's an
unspeakable humanitarian catastrophe a
national security catastrophe 302,000
people came over the Border in DEC
but they know this Mr Speaker so you
going over to the White House today I
mean I understand you want to show
comedy with the the Democrats and and
and you're you're you have a reputation
wanting to work with there and that's
that's great if you're working with
people who actually have the same goals
as you have and I think your goals here
by by all indication your goals are the
goals of the Grassroots of the
Republican party and most most Americans
by the way but that is not their goal if
it were their goal they would have
enforced the bord so you're in negoti
with people who don't have your your
same uh goals and mind so you're just
giving them the Fig Leaf of
bipartisanship here or they're going to
blame you if this goes south Laura we
have to do everything we can do drag
them Kicking and Screaming over the line
but that's our job is to forge that
consensus to make it happen I I'm only I
only have the control of one chamber one
one house of Congress and we have the
smallest majority in US history quite
literally this week with people out sick
so we're doing everything we can we have
to use every oun of Leverage and make
them do the right thing that's what
we're trying to force no one is twisting
my arm it's quite the opposite I'm there
at the White House demanding action on
behalf of the American people and the
House Republicans going to are going to
stand on that ground we have been
consistently and will continue to do so
if Ukraine is really the positively
absolutely has to be a priority which
I'm certainly not for but if if if they
desperate to get money to Ukraine again
the American people aren't for that I
think it's only 41% in our Fox voter
analysis poll in you in in Iowa say they
want to give more money to to Ukraine
but if you guys all want to do that do a
Ukraine Bill Standalone why tie that to
our border well Ukraine is leveraged to
get border but to your point they may
indeed be broken up we'll see how it all
develops again the devil's going to be
in the details on all these these uh
proposals but what's happening in
Ukraine is is not acceptable the status
quo is not acceptable we've sent
billions of dollars over there without
any clear articulation of the strategy
and I've been telling the White House
this as well what is the strategy what's
the end game how do we have
accountability dollars of taxpayers why
give more money they fail talk about
failing that's not failing upward
they're just failing yeah we've been
pressing the White House every day for
answers to critical questions the
American people are owed and we have to
know that we have to know strategy
ingame how do we get how does Ukraine
get out of that conflict why aren't the
critical Weapons Systems that have been
requested and necessary to push Russia
back been supplied by the White House I
mean I met with president zalinsky when
he was in town last before Christmas and
he said they haven't gotten the weapon
system they asked for so in other words
the White House is not even providing
the assistance that has been needed and
and yet they're asking for more billions
there's a lot of work yet here to be
done and I understand the frustration of
the American people we share it as well
that's the problem and Mr and Mr Speaker
one final question given the fact that
many in the House of Representatives
believe Alejandra mayorca should be
impeached for failing to do his job do
you believe whatever is agreed to in the
so-called border uh deal would in any
way be implemented on the enforcement
Side by a man who's allowed our border
to be open on the direction of the Biden
team absolutely not Laura mayorcas is
responsible for this he engineered the
open border he he is the one that's done
that so to your point it doesn't matter
what laws we pass if the secretary of
the Department of Homeland Security is
unable or unwilling to enforce them I
think he's unwilling in this case then
it it makes no no difference and and
that's the point I I think the White
House and the president president
himself has to take executive action he
has to do what he has the authority
under existing law to solve this mess to
end the catastrophy that he and his
agencies including mayorcas have created
we're going to insist upon that we have
been every single day we'll continue to
because we owe that to the American
people does the fact that President
Trump that he stands so strongly against
this deal is that important to you well
I mean again president Trump and I have
talked about this we don't know what the
deal is we haven't seen it yet we know
what it is it's a fig it's a promise of
enforcement with with millions of people
in the next decade coming into the
country across the border that's the
that's the deal that's a nutshell that's
a deal two lines tell I just told I just
told everybody at the White House
everybody sitting around that room that
we need the elements of hr2 the
functional equivalent thereof I don't
care what they call it but you have to
make these changes to solve the problem
the deputy secretary of of uh the border
patrol US border patol a 33-year veteran
of the agency told us at Eagle Pass two
and a half weeks ago three weeks ago
brought 64 House Republicans down there
he said it's as if I'm administering an
open fire hydrant I don't need more
buckets I need to turn down the flow
that's what we have to do to save the
country to help save the country is
turned down the FL and get all these
illegals down Mr Speaker we really appre
appreciate you're joining us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else